Now, you can imagine that if I have a linear factor that has a negative
coefficient in front of the X that I can actually pull that negative out and
instead write the factor in an equivalent from with a positive coefficient for
X. The negative can be reflected in the other factor that we're multiplying by.
This basically means that I can choose which coefficients go in front of our X
term. And if I want, I can decide that I want those to be positive. That's
definitely what I would prefer, just for ease of looking at our factorization.
So let's just go ahead and remove the negative number pairs that multiply to
equal 6. This makes our lives much easier. Now we only have two pairs of
coefficients to check to put in these slots instead of four. So let's do just
that. Let's check them. I've written out for you two possible ways of factoring
our original expression of 6x squared minus 7x minus 5. Actually only one of
these 2 ways is possible because you know that only one of these combinations of
coefficients for x actually works. So for the one that works you're going to
figure that out by figuring out which number belongs here and here or here and
here depending on which one is right and then on the equation that's not going
to work at all based on these first 2 coefficients. You're going to simply
bubble in wrong for the 2 constant term slots. So basically, try out each of the
4 numbers that are written down here, which you notice are the 4 different
factors of negative 5 that you found earlier. And once you find out which one
works, fill in the proper numbers and then rule out the other entire equation.